[Music]
the Oscars are just three days away Oh
an excitement building Oh somewhere and
what you're just making random noises
I'm speechless okay the excitement just
or I might be having some sort of
medical conditions yeah well I'll go
with that one well there are nine
nominees for Best Picture the problem is
a lot of you haven't seen all of the
movies and Andy and I once again we want
to help okay
each night we've been performing a
pivotal scene from one of the nominated
films so that this weekend when you're
watching with friends you'll kind of
know what's going on all right we're
gonna bring you up to speed
we're here for you yes the last two
nights we perform scenes from the artist
and that went very well very well and
the help very Todd yeah touching tonight
we've chosen warhorse
okay to set up the scene Andy you will
be playing the horse yes okay there's a
costume for you into the couch and Andy
will put on the costume and become
magically War Horse all right
beautiful and incredible transformation
Wow the walking is sup well he ruined it
by sitting down okay and I will be
playing captain Nichols a young Calvary
officer heading off to fight and in need
of a horse so I'll put on this vintage
cap which immediately transforms me into
a world war one soldier or a
turn-of-the-century newsboy message for
mr. o'brien we got a message yeah
the powerful scene we'll be doing is
when Captain Nichols meets the war horse
for the first time it has to win the
horses trust the horse isn't sure it's a
very powerful scene are you ready to do
this Andy I sure AM Conan okay we now
present you a scene from War Horse and
begin by look at that horse I think I'll
take him to war
don't be so skittish war horse no no no
come here War Horse come to me no no no
War Horse don't be shot no don't be shy
Oh peas please won't kill you know what
just screw it yeah hit it Jimmy let's do
it this way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]